Dark Phoenix ended in era for the x-men
franchise and unfortunately it didn't
end on a high note from rotten reviews
to disappointing box office receipts
this superhero sequel is far from super
and the writing was on the wall long
before it arrived in theaters here's a
spoiler filled look at why Dark Phoenix
bombed in late January 2019 dark
Phoenix's test screenings bombed
dramatically 20th Century Fox knew they
had to fix it but in spite of extensive
reshoots including major changes to the
climax because of perceived similarities
to the ending of another superhero film
critics still savaged Dark Phoenix which
earned a rotten tomato score so low it's
on par with disasters like 2015's
Fantastic Four 2004's Catwoman and the
Titanic not the movie the actual ship
Brian Talarico at Roger Ebert calms some
things up simply calling the film a
joyless lifeless boring affair that's
not good
even if critical response had been
better Dark Phoenix faced an uphill
battle at the theater thanks to strong
competition from hit films John wick
chapter 3 Disney's live-action remake of
Aladdin and the secret life of pets 2
and with box-office juggernaut Avengers
endgame still in theaters even superhero
fans had other options Dark Phoenix
could have avoided these problems if it
had debuted in February as originally
planned but according to reports Fox
moved it to make room for another bomb
at least domestically Alita battle angel
way to double down guys you could argue
that the fate of Dark Phoenix was sealed
way back in December 2017 when it was
announced that Disney was planning to
acquire 20th Century Fox because that
kind of make Dark Phoenix a lame duck
gross
no not that lame duck
but even Howard benefits from being part
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe these
days superhero fans love shared
universes the idea of bringing the x-men
into the MCU is exciting but it also
made Dark Phoenix seem kind of pointless
as fans really just want to see what the
new Marvel version of the team is going
to look like especially since other than
Logan the quality of the MCU films has
been so much higher than most of Fox's
x-men offerings the x-men series has had
more ups and downs than a rollercoaster
after hitting rock bottom with 2006's
x-men The Last Stand the franchise
rebounded in a big way with the 2011
prequel x-men first class and its
follow-up 2014 ambitious time-travel
epic x-men Days of Future past but
things went sour very fast in 2016 with
x-men apocalypse disappointing fans and
critics alike the film was poorly
received and failed to break even at the
domestic box office earning most of its
money overseas as a result Dark Phoenix
started in a hole to begin with as it
had to convince viewers to return to a
franchise that had already disappointed
them and it clearly failed to do so one
of the most disappointing aspects of
Dark Phoenix is the relative absence of
Quicksilver a fan favorite who stole
scenes in both Days of Future past and
apocalypse Quicksilver is sidelined
early on in Dark Phoenix and gets almost
no screen time
there's not even a resolution to the
long-running subplot that he has
secretly the son of magneto and then
there's the absence of Wolverine on the
one hand Hugh Jackman made it clear that
he's done playing Logan so there's
basically no chance he would have been
in the film eventually you're gonna hang
up the claws and it's gonna make a lot
of people very sad huh on the other hand
well Dark Phoenix really needed him the
only real argument otherwise is the fact
that even Jackman couldn't save things
the last time they made a movie from
this story speaking of that Dark Phoenix
loosely adapts the classic Marvel
storyline the Dark Phoenix saga sound
familiar
it's
Phoenix Phoenix dark Dirk Phoenix well
if it seems familiar it might be because
the same story was also adapted in 2006
as x-men The Last Stand yes despite more
than 55 years worth of stories to choose
from Fox for some reason decided to
adapt the same story twice
even though The Last Stand was widely
disliked by fans and critics alike why
repeat the same mistake it's just weird
with x-men premiering in 2000 and Dark
Phoenix acting as the series finale the
x-men franchise is ending as it's just
about to turn 20 years old it's arguably
ending later than it should have the box
office landscape has changed a lot since
x-men was first released and franchise
fatigue has set in Marvel has the
benefit of multiple franchises you don't
get tired of the Avengers because in
between those films you get the
guardians of the galaxy or a black
panther to mix things up but at Fox it's
all x-men all the time if anything
spin-off hits like Logan and Deadpool
proved just how tired the x-men formula
has become as both of those movies
succeeded by intentionally doing
something different and playing off of
expectations Dark Phoenix on the other
hand is exactly what you thought and
feared it was
it's a sad way for the franchise to end
but it's also a happy occasion for fans
to see the characters move over to the
MCU it's long past due for Marvel's
mutants to come home and realize their
full potential check out one of our
newest videos right here
Plus even more looper videos about your
favorite superheroes are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]